the vast majority of news in the u.s. is
controlled by five huge corporations and
news voice is fighting back against
media monopolies it's the first-ever
entirely open crowd-sourced democratized
platform for news use the link right
underneath this video to download the
news voice app for free history is not
aware of any president that has lied as
much as Donald Trump has lied often that
number 12,000 lies is thrown around that
number is now outdated we have an
updated number the Washington Post has
been tracking Donald Trump's lies and
misleading claims for his presidency
they have updated the number it is now
fifteen thousand four hundred and
thirteen false or misleading claims over
one thousand fifty five days now before
we move on I do want to address a lot of
people will email me they'll say David
why don't media outlets just call them
lies you will notice that the Washington
Post stays away from the word lie they
there's a lot of interesting legal stuff
behind that behind the hesitation from
corporate media to actually call a lie a
lie and from what I've been told by
attorneys in the field they say when you
call something a lie you're signaling
intent and you're signaling a certain
level of calculation and it's hard to do
that so instead media outlets tend to
say the statement was factually
inaccurate it was misleading but I think
we all understand more than 15-thousand
lies and incorrect statements and
misleading claims by Donald Trump during
his presidency and it does not matter
by the way ramping up the lies in 2019
and 2017 Trump told only about 2,000
lies and 2018 it went up to about 5,700
and in 2019 so far we still have a
couple weeks left and they could be
doozies Donald Trump has told 7,700 lies
what has really kicked up the number of
lies in recent a couple of months it
have been the record lies of related to
the Ukraine Fiasco that has caused just
a persistent stream of endless lies from
Donald Trump but I want to get back to
the consequences which are probably none
all of these talking points from the
write about
alternative facts fake news the lying
dishonest corrupt media as Donald Trump
likes to say these talking points have
worked and we on the Left I've set for a
long time we're pretty bad at messaging
and and talking points and influence on
the left on a lot of different issues
and Donald Trump has really successfully
developed these phrases and talking
points the people who realize Trump lies
all the time are probably not voting for
him already mostly mostly with some
exceptions the trumpets have already
been convinced by the talking points a
media outlet says something negative
about Trump it's got to be fake news an
apparent disagreement about simple facts
it's just perspective it's a sort of new
right-wing post-modernism we have
alternative facts as the phrase and I'm
reminded once again about 1984 versus
brave new world these are two prominent
dystopian novels along with one called
we which is lesser-known but I still
recommend reading it 1984 by George
Orwell brave new world by Aldous Huxley
and Neil postman one wrote once wrote
quote what Orwell feared were those who
would ban books
what Huxley feared was that there would
be no reason to ban a book for there
would be no one who wanted to read one
Orwell feared those who would deprive us
of information Huxley feared those who
would give us so much that we would be
reduced to passivity and egoism Orwell
feared that the truth would be concealed
from us Huxley feared the truth would be
drowned in a sea of irrelevance Orwell
feared we would become a captive culture
Huxley feared we would become a trivial
culture now I don't want to write off
the ways in which 2019
Trumpy in America is like 1984 there's a
combination of both 1984 and brave new
world there is some banning of
information I mean look at what Trump
did to NASA on climate change research
that they were doing and we have many
other examples but more importantly or
more significantly maybe for Trump
avoiding consequences from his lies in
propaganda
is that Trump has created a culture of
Oh Trump is in another scandal and it
becomes irrelevant scandal fatigue the
moniker of fake news when you get
confused I hear one set of facts and
another set of facts they don't need to
ban contradicting contradictory facts
they just put out a counter-narrative
people say what the hell I'm gonna go
back to my video games or my Netflix
shows or whatever the case may be
claims of a witch-hunt against him all
of this stuff is much more like brave
new world than 1984 it's part 1984 but a
big part brave new world and it's scary
stuff make sure you're following us on
Instagram for more on this and every
other story from today's show we are at
david pakman show on instagram by the
way I posted a picture of me with my
dad's dog on my Instagram today he is
ready for Chanukah very much ready
follow me on instagram at david pakman
quick break part two of my interview
with Jenn Kyogre next and then much more